when i got to work as secretary of state
i opted for convenience to use my
personal email account which was allowed
by the state department because i
thought it would be easier to carry just
one device for my work and for my
personal emails instead of two the vast
majority of my work emails went to
government employees at their government
addresses which meant they were captured
and preserved immediately on the system
at the State Department we went through
a thorough process to identify all of my
work related emails and deliver them to
the State Department I took the
unprecedented step of asking that the
State Department make all my work
related emails public for everyone to
see going through the emails there were
over 60,000 in total sent and received
about half were work-related and went to
the State Department and about half were
personal that were not in any way
related to my work I had no reason to
save them but that was my decision
because the federal guidelines are clear
and the State Department request was
clear for any government employee it is
that government employees responsibility
to determine what's personal and what's
work-related the laws and regulations in
effect when I was Secretary of State
allowed me to use my email for work that
is undisputed looking back it would have
been better for me to use two separate
phones and two email accounts I thought
using one device would be simpler and
obviously it hasn't worked out that way